[Musica]
vorrei ragionare insieme a voi di come
il design possa essere un approccio per
fare innovazione sociale
ma che cos'è l'innovazione sociale e
progettare un processo di lavoro che si
pone l'obiettivo di migliorare la
qualità della vita delle persone e
quindi la società non ci si limita
quindi a progettare per un risultato
finale come un tavolo una sedia o una
lavatrice ma si pongono le condizioni
affinché un determinato evento abbia
maggiori possibilità di accadere ciò che
dobbiamo fare è intercettare una sfida
sociale o individuare un problema da
risolvere ma prima di pensare alla
soluzione
entrare nel punto di vista di chi quel
prodotto o quel servizio lo dovrà
utilizzare ma proviamo a semplificare
con un caso pratico questo seguendo la
trasformazione di un carcere italiano
san vittore entriamo nel merito ma prima
di farlo
vorrei sapere
chi di voi non è mai entrato in un
carcere
provato a ripensare l'ultima volta in
cui l'avete visto
che di voi lo ha guardato con distacco e
diffidenza
più o meno gli stessi
immaginatevi il carcere del futuro
aperto e connesso con la città capace di
valorizzare il tempo detentivo in tempo
utile per favorire il reintegro in
società dei detenuti e al contempo
migliorare la qualità della vita delle
persone che ci vivono e ci lavorano
all'interno vista la sfida complessa
occorreva un team trans disciplinare e
su richiesta della direzione carceraria
con fondazione triennale fondazione
maimeri fondazione di comunità e amici
della nave siamo partiti dal
ripensamento degli spazi non ci siamo
limitati però ad un intervento di tipo
architettonico ma volevamo porre le basi
affinché si potessero integrare
funzioni e servizi nuovi utili allo
scopo
ma vediamo meglio lo human center e
design era l'approccio giusto per questo
tipo di sfida è una disciplina che
prevede di mantenere l'essere umano
al centro del progetto di innovazione e
quindi di empatizzare e di guardare con
gli occhi di chi vive quotidianamente un
determinato contesto in questo caso il
carcere
era necessario vivere in prima persona
l'esperienza del carcere entrare e
passare del tempo là dentro
dovevamo capire come le persone
interagivano fra di loro come
interagivano con gli oggetti come
interagivano quegli spazi e dovevamo
vedere come poter ripensare degli spazi
esistenti abbiamo scoperto che in alcuni
spazi potevamo far accadere delle cose
nuove e abbiamo anche scoperto che in
altri spazi
avevano un potenziale inespresso ma
dovevamo capire che cosa fare
occorrevano delle interviste one to one
con detenuti agenti di polizia volontari
e vista la complessità del contesto
dovevamo utilizzare la metodologia della
prestativi inquiry che prevede di
raccogliere informazioni positive
proietta la persona intervistata dal
presente nel futuro ed evita di
collezionare vincoli problemi e
frustrazioni pensate che le convinzioni
iniziali di partenza erano che per il
detenuto il problema primario fosse la
cella e invece abbiamo scoperto che per
lui è molto importante l'impatto che la
sua detenzione ha nei confronti della
sua famiglia ha necessità di relazioni
solide affettive con i propri figli che
non c'entrano nulla con i suoi errori
e il fatto di ricostruire delle
esperienze di incontro più positive a
ricostruire delle esperienze di gioco i
luoghi che siano più casa e meno carcere
gli consiglierei gli consentirebbe di
essere genitori anche da dentro il
detenuto ha paura del fuori del dopo sa
perfettamente che quando sarà in libertà
la società lo escluderà e lui rischierà
di sbagliare ancora
viene forte l'esigenza di uscire da un
attesa passiva
e intraprendere dei percorsi per
ritrovare una nuova identità e per
formarsi e per ridurre aggressività e
frustrazione è necessario che si prenda
cura di qualche cosa ogni giorno fosse
anche una pianta è la cosa più
interessante l'abbiamo scoperto
intervistando gli agenti di polizia
penitenziaria pensate che a san vittore
lavorano più di 600 agenti e più del 50
per cento vive all'interno
vivono in alloggi che sono all'interno
delle zone detentive in spazi che un
tempo erano celle tanto per intenderci
alle loro finestre ci sono le sbarre
vivono in camerate comuni condividono
spazi comuni e se cambiano in corridoio
questo significa che se un agente fa il
turno di notte rientra al mattino gli
altri colleghi per non disturbarlo e per
suo rispetto escono e si cambiano in
corridoio vivono costantemente vincolati
nelle azioni fanno la vita del carcere
io mi sono relazionato con loro e vi
garantisco che fare quel tipo di lavoro
in quel tipo di condizione comporta un
elevatissimo senso di strass la loro
testa non stacca mai ma immaginatevi voi
di tornare a casa la sera dove
oltrepassare quelle sbarre ogni volta e
non avere mai uno spazio per la vostra
privacy e nemmeno per la semplice
lettura di un libro
gli agenti di polizia penitenziaria
desiderano un maggior riconoscimento
sociale
all'esterno rispetto al duro lavoro che
fanno
è necessario che ci sia per loro degli
spazi che gli consentano di
rilassarsi avere confort
rigenerarsi isolarsi non ci sono spazi
affinché le famiglie che i figli che
talvolta vengono da lontano in qualche
modo possano avere relazioni con loro e
la distanza delle famiglie fa nascere in
loro il desiderio di avere spazi
positivi di socializzazione e dove avere
delle conversazioni positive
ma sapete che cosa ci hanno detto gli
esperti
ci hanno confermato
dell'importanza di ingaggiare i detenuti
in percorsi di riabilitazione che gli
consentono di trovare una nuova identità
orientarsi e professionalizzarsi è la
cosa più interessante che i bisogni
dell'esterno di persone che vivono nel
quartiere ci hanno confermato dello
stacco fisso fra dentro fuori e della
volontà di trovare le modalità affinché
il carcere possa scambiare meglio con la
città e ci hanno anche evidenziato come
siano necessarie all'interno di quel
quartiere degli spazi verdi
avevamo raccolto tutti i bisogni ma
dovevamo fare di più
era necessario ispirarci con dei casi
studio nazionali e internazionali per
vedere come in altre carceri del nord
europa erano stati risolti gli stessi
bisogni ed era anche interessante vedere
come gli stessi bisogni erano stati
risolti in complessi completamente
differenti ma tra un attimo vedremo come
raccolto tutto questo patrimonio che
proveniva dalle persone che popolano
l'interno e l'esterno del carcere
potevamo
intraprendere la strada dell'ideazione
con la metodologia del co design che
significa progettare insieme potevamo
definire delle linee d'intervento
sapendo di dover rispondere a bisogni
interni e esterne al carcere ma
vediamole insieme
interazione con la città comunità spazi
abitativi ricreatività e benessere la
prima immaginatevi dei luoghi che
consentano l'interazione spontanea lo
scambio e le reazioni positive sia per
agenti sia per i detenuti che in qualche
modo consentano di costruire delle
relazioni di fiducia e interazione con
la città se da un lato e importante
riconnettere i detenuti con la città
attraverso la creazione di spazio
positivi dall'altro san vittore stesso
ha necessità di entrare in contatto con
la città condividendo degli spazi verdi
e di cultura ricreatività e benessere
luoghi dove poter scoprire nuove
passioni allenare talenti esistenti ma
vediamo nel dettaglio community space di
reparto sia per gli agenti e sia per i
detenuti
l'utilizzo del cibo come strumento per
creare delle relazioni positive la
collaborazione spontanea la condivisione
luoghi dove poter instaurare delle
relazioni di comunità campus dei talenti
scuola professionale multi tech a spazi
per gli agenti dove poter allenare il
proprio talento scoprirne di nuovi
imparare un mestiere migliorare nel
mestiere che si conosce e rendere il
tempo del detenuto più produttivo e
proficuo spazio polifunzionale e
flessibile mensa e bar per gli agenti
per gli agenti luoghi versatili in grado
di ospitare celebrazioni di eventi fra
colleghi poter ospitare i familiari in b
i figli in visita i luoghi
trasformabili affinché si possa ospitare
arte musica cultura in genere come
motore di interscambio dentro fuori con
la città e luoghi dove si possono
costruire relazioni di qualità fra
agenti e città non potevamo non
intervenire nell'ambito della privacy e
del relax in caserma che era la
proprietà luoghi dove la gente si possa
ristorare rilassarsi e rigenerarsi
sentirsi a casa
in questo caso è stato molto
interessante nella fase di desk research
avere individuato come in una lavanderia
di hong kong sia stata pensata per la
socializzazione per prendersi un caffè
guardare un film nell'attesa di ricevere
il bucato e poi colloqui incontri spazi
più positivi più caldi più casa che
consentono appunto dall'interno di
continuerà a essere genitore ma
soprattutto di abbattere l'impatto
negativo che il carcere ha nei confronti
dei bambini
e spazi comuni all'aperto luoghi
condivisi fra carcere città dove poter
fare sport seriamente all'aperto e dove
i cittadini e gli agenti insieme possono
costruire delle relazioni di qualità ma
soprattutto
avvicinare questi due mondi che sono
totalmente
lontani solo dopo tutta questa
ideazione di linee di intervento siamo
pure siamo potuti passare alla fase di
progettazione in una logica unitaria
significa poter coinvolgere più studi di
progettazione
commetterli in un'unica visione e
sincerarci che le progettualità
rispondessero a tutti i bisogni interni
ed esterni
anch'io come voi aveva un senso di
diffidenza davanti a quel muro e di
distacco e anche di paura e questo
stesso progetto mi ha trasformato
occuparmi di inclusività e diversità
ogni giorno mi ha accorciato le distanze
io non sono un esperto di carcere sono
un imprenditore
so perfettamente che questa è una sfida
seria e complessa e so perfettamente che
questa non è la risposta assoluta e
risolutiva è solo l'esempio di come il
design sia capace di tenere le persone
al centro con i loro bisogni e attivare
dei processi trasformativi anche in
luoghi così complessi e inaspettati
spero con questo mio contributo di aver
ridotto di qualche centimetro la
distanza anche a voi grazie per avermi
ascoltato
[Applauso]